das elend liegt in ungarn am rande der
posten
hier ist eine komische in einer roma
siedlung unterwegs um den ärmsten zu
helfen
heute bringt sie familie horvath
lebensmittel und medikamente
[Musik]
die familie lebt mit 19 menschen in vier
zimmern
es fehlt an allem jeder bekommt nur
einen euro sozialhilfe am tag
was habt ihr im kühlschrank nichts aniko
erst leer
die ganze familie ernährt sich aus
diesem topf wir haben gerade kein holz
mehr zum heizen das holz das vom amt
gekommen ist hat gerade für zwei zimmer
gerecht wir heizen mit lappen und
schuhen wenn uns holz fehlt aniko cash
ist eine pensionierte professoren
seit zehn jahren engagiert sie sich in
einer hilfsorganisation weil die armut
dieser familien sie so erschüttert
manche menschen sind von der winterkälte
so erschöpft dass sie sterben erzählt
sie ich kenne solche fälle
sie frieren haben schlechte kleidung zu
wenig essen entzündungen die armut
schwächt das immunsystem manche sterben
am ende durch die kälte hat vaio schon
die armut in chören passt nicht ganz zu
der erzählung vom wirtschaftlich
erfolgreichen ungarn die ungarns
regierungschef viktor orban gerne
vermittelt tausende stehen in ungarn
mittags für ein stück brot und einen
apfel an orban mittags speisung nennen
sie das
selbst der bürgermeister sagt hier gibt
es keine armut und die regierung will
auch nicht über die armut reden
es ist ein tabu sie sind daran nicht
interessiert
für sie ist der tourismus wichtiger da
stecken sie geld rein
die tiefe armut möchten sie nicht sehen
in der tat das schöne budapest hat man
mit viel geld noch schöner gemacht
die armen haben davon nichts verdient
haben daran viktor orbáns freunde
bauunternehmer und oligarchen die armut
im land und orban erfolg wie passt das
zusammen
ich treffe einen weggefährten von viktor
orban gabor fodor hat mit orban die
fidesz partei gegründet hier ein foto
von früher orban in der mitte doch
längst hat vor doch mit bann gebrochen
wir wollten eine gesellschaft in die
reinen das talent vorantreibt und nicht
das vitamin b die größte sünde dieser
regierung ist dass sie die
vetternwirtschaft nicht abstellt sondern
damit weiter macht um orban besser zu
verstehen schilderte er mir seinen
ersten auftritt 89 hier auf dem
heldenplatz viktor orban redet vor
zehntausenden er spricht als einziger
aus was ungern denkt nach dieser rede
kennt ihn jeder
wir können eine regierung wählen die
verhandlungen beginnt über den
sofortigen abzug der sowjetischen
truppen die nationale unabhängigkeit und
politische freiheit diese unsere ziele
haben sich bis heute nicht geändert
diese patriotische botschaft sendet
orban bis heute hier weil er ein
nationales mahnmal ein es zeigt unter
anderem orte in rumänien der slowakei
und kroatien die aber bis vor gut 100
jahren zum gros ungarischen reich
gehörten die verkleinerung ungarns
damals hat man bis heute nicht verwunden
sogar vor organs frisch sanierte man
sitz wehen die flaggen groß ungarischer
fürstentümer das wäre in etwa so als
wenn vor dem deutschen kanzleramt die
fahnen aus schlesien und preußen räten
wieso macht er das geht es natürlich die
frage wie es den ungarn jenseits der
grenze geht ist auch vielen ungarn in
der heimat wichtig wichtiger jedenfalls
als die soziale lage lieber inszeniert
sich orban als retter einer
unterdrückten nation unterdrückt von den
habsburgern den sowjets und jetzt von
brüssel so die rhetorik wir haben uns
das ziel gesetzt uns und der welt zu
beweisen dass wir noch jemand sind dass
wir noch jemand sind was wohl diese
männer dazu sagen
sie stehen hier bei der obdachlosenhilfe
an weil es ihnen in ungarn gesetzlich
verboten ist auf der straße zu leben
die polizei hat mich eingesperrt
ich sollte eine strafe zahlen aber ich
habe gesagt ich gehe lieber in einem
obdachlosenheim
ich habe das geld nicht garbani leitet
das heim
er war früher organs pfarrer heute
gehöre zu seinen größten kritiker
es gibt zwei gruppen in ungarn 60
prozent der menschen können sich eine
akzeptable lebensform sichern
was mit den anderen 40 prozent ist
brauche ich ihn ja nicht zu sagen
zum heim gehören auch eine
krankenstation und eine wärmestube
ungarn bekommt auch bruttoinlandsprodukt
gerechnet die meisten eu subventionen
wie so landet davon fast nichts bei den
ärmsten orban ist putins treuester
schüler er macht politik für sich selbst
wo er kein geld abzapfen kann das
interessiert ihn nicht
egal was ist er muss an der spitze
stehen überall das hätten wir gerne auch
mit viktor orbáns regierungssprecher
gesprochen
doch trotz mehrmaliger bemühungen kann
kein interview zustande
die wirtschaftliche lage hat sich für
viele ungarn leicht verbessert in den
vergangenen jahren vor allem in den
städten
doch in orten wie töre kommt von orbáns
mantra wir sind wieder wer nicht viel an
helferin eine cookies sagt die regierung
muss sich endlich um die armen kümmern
und nicht um organs reiche freunde und
familie horvath
[Musik]
ich bete zum lieben gott dass meine
enkel in besseren verhältnissen
aufwachsen können
die ärmsten in köln das tabu in orbáns
schönem ungarn
[Musik]